foreign
welcome back to another episode of the
addy hour it's always my joy and
pleasure to host these important
conversations hard to believe this is
episode 39 already so I definitely
appreciate all the support that you all
have given and just all the feedback
from so many listeners I was just
mentioning offline with today's guest I
actually came back from a talk where
some of the people that were
participating in a research institute I
actually looked at one of our podcasts
and had a small group discussion about
it so it's really encouraging to hear
all the different ways that you all are
really benefiting from this and helping
using it to help you think about things
in a different kind of way
so today I'm honored to be able to host
a conversation about topics that are
near and dear to this podcast we're
going to be talking about mental health
and the church tension or hope or even
tension and hope and I'm honored to be
able to welcome a wonderful guest to the
podcast today's guest is Dr Tama Bryant
so Dr Brian thank you so much for being
here oh thank you so much for having me
I'm so excited and have been looking
forward to the conversation
wonderful well I'm definitely excited as
well and this is something that I'm I'm
really uh curious to see where we go
because there's so many different
directions that we could take this
conversation so just to give you all
those listeners a quick and uh quick
introduction to Dr Tama for those of you
who might not be familiar with her Dr
Tama is a tenured professor of
psychology at Pepperdine University
where she also directs the culture and
Trauma research laboratory she is
someone who has clinical interests in
interpersonal trauma also on societal
trauma and oppression and she's been
really instrumental in her career over
the years really raising public
awareness regarding mental health by
extending the reach of psychology beyond
the academy and also Beyond private
therapy to really reach into communities
through things like Community
programming organizational consultation
popular books and media engagement so
he's also the current president of the
American Psychological Association also
known as the APA so a very influential
organization in this country which we'll
hear more about as we we jump into the
conversation she has numerous Awards too
many to mention here so I'm just going
to leave that and say that she does have
numerous Awards but I do want to mention
a couple of the things that she's
involved in so in addition to being the
APA president she hosts a podcast called
homecoming which is a mental health
podcast she's also the director of the
mental health Ministry at her church the
First AME Church in South Los Angeles
and she's the author of several books
and articles one I wanted to mention is
called homecoming overcome fear and
Trauma to reclaim your whole authentic
self so someone who has definitely been
influential in society and in the field
and I'm just grateful and honored to be
able to welcome here here again to the
program today oh thank you so much for
having me I really appreciate it and
we're excited at the American
Psychological Association to get ready
to host you as one of our invited
speakers at the August annual convention
in Washington DC so so much gratitude
for the work that you do do I definitely
appreciate that I'm really looking
forward to that just be able to to be
engaged with that group not to detract
too much but that's to take me back a
little bit because as our listeners know
I'm a neuroscientist but during my
sabbatical a few years ago I actually
spent time with Clinical Psychology
interns um in the Bronx in New York at
Montefiore hospital and that really
informed some of the work that we're
doing on this podcast so in a way the
APA invitation is full circle for me I'm
really excited about it oh wonderful I
love that and the application and
integration because often we have these
separate uh profound conversations that
are happening in our sub fields and
sub-disciplines and so when we can
connect and really exchange across those
different lines it's really uh
phenomenal yeah I definitely agree well
you're going to be primed and ready
already okay good which is wonderful so
as my listeners also know I always like
to just check in with our guests to see
where they are at in this point in time
and how they're doing overall I think
it's very appropriate but then also I'm
fortunate that we have to acknowledge
that even as we're recording we're only
a couple days past yet another school
shooting something that we've had to
talk about too often on this podcast
just the frequency with which that's
happening and definitely want to take
time to just commiserate and mourn and
agree with all those who are affected by
that but in that Spirit just wanted to
see how you are doing at this point in
time just with everything that we
continue to navigate as a society
yes so I am doing well even as I think
about all of the traumas that we are
exposed to in our individual lives and
also as a collective uh and I am able to
do well I think by being mindful of the
number of people who are working to make
things better and so that nourishes me
so it doesn't feel like me against the
world right there are uh many
like-minded people who are in their own
way or in their own discipline or in
their own communities uh working for the
transformation and so that nourishes me
and then on a personal note I'm also a
mom and my daughter is a senior in high
school so we are in that busy season of
college applications and prom and
graduation uh so that is really making
me thoughtful about seizing the time and
the moment you know that she'll be going
into another season so for each of us to
think about like the gift of now and
being present you know showing up for
those that we love and so that really
means a lot to me um well I really
appreciate that and that just sounds
like such a healthy perspective to be
able to hold all those pieces together
um especially knowing that there are
challenges that people are going through
but then as you mentioned knowing that
there are those who are about to work
and even as you were talking as I was
there for reflecting also just thinking
about someone like you and your role and
your focus on some of the
trauma-informed work just wondering if
you could even expand on how you
continue to have that healthy balance so
much so that the work itself or what
you're helping people navigate through
doesn't become overwhelming for you on a
day-to-day basis yes so thank you for
that question a lot of times when people
hear that I'm along with being an
educator I'm in practice and working
primarily with trauma survivors and so
people will often say oh that must be
depressing but it actually is quite
inspiring because
uh survivors are incredible people you
know they're often we wear it well and
people if you just encounter some
someone on the bus or at work or in the
supermarket you know you don't really
know their story but I get the
opportunity to be able to Bear witness
and to hear people's stories and you
know in that African-American culture we
would say kind of anyhow like what they
have done anyhow is amazing not only you
know you think about maybe
professionally but personally to still
be a loving person to be a kind person
to have Grace
um is is remarkable given what some
people have survived and so
um seeing people's courage and tenacity
to try to live well is remarkable and
then I also do work on the side of
prevention I think if you're only
working in the aftermath it can feel
like you know what's the point there's
always like going to be another school
shooting or another sexual assault or
another child who's been abused but when
you get to also work in helping stop the
cycle so not only do I work with
survivors but I have also worked with
persons who have offended and so knowing
that it's a choice and that people can
make another Choice
um really helps me to keep showing up
wow there's a lot there I think on both
sides even aspects of Grace and things I
want to definitely come back to and kind
of peel back the layers on but before we
get there just also wondered if you'd
give our listeners a little bit of a
sense of how you got into this work in
the first place and how you develop this
passion for the work that you do yes I
love to share it I am actually a
pastor's daughter and so uh for the the
um within the African-American Community
a lot of times people feel more
comfortable talking to their Minister
than a therapist or psychologist or
social worker and so growing up I often
saw people coming to meet really with
both of my parents for what we would
call pastoral care or pastoral
Counseling in my book homecoming I say
my teen years were my first years
working at a crisis hotline because
people would just call call the house at
all hours of night and day just with
whatever they were holding and so
um I learned very early I would be what
people would describe as sensitive and
you can either think of like sensitive
people as that's a problem or that's a
resource or a strength that we feel
things deeply and you know really
empathize with others
um and have a love for for listening and
for being of service
um and so you know I was exposed to
pastoral counseling and then I
discovered like that it's a field in and
of itself this is like something where
people you know Focus their life's work
and on human behavior and human
interaction and kind of working to the
service to to betterment uh to better uh
society and humanity and so initially I
thought I wanted uh to practice
full-time and then when I applied to
Duke University where we both attended
they really have a focus on those who
want to do research and at first it
wasn't a passion of mine but it's all
about getting the right exposure and I
ended up working with a faculty member
Susan Roth who works from the
perspective of feminist psychology which
means not just looking at the individual
but paying attention to the systems in
which people live and how to transform
those as well as individuals and so that
really got me excited and also she does
qualitative research which is uh
documenting people's stories
and
um I love stories and I love
storytelling and so that got me
interested in research and teaching as
well
that's wonderful to hear about a journey
in so many different pieces and again
and one of the themes I keep hearing as
you're talking about just how you're
doing day to day when you're talking
about your passion your educational
experience it's also just your ability
to kind of hold different pieces
together even as you were talking about
thinking about the individual also
thinking about the systems as you were
talking about the work that you've done
with those who are survivors but then
also working with offenders and so I
think there's a lot of strength that
likely comes from that as well and then
even as you talked about being
empathetic and seeing that as a as a
strength and a way to kind of navigate
and help people through because I think
in so many instances people do see that
but they also see or feel the burden
because maybe things aren't and there's
never any sense of True Balance but
things are too skewed on one side or the
other so I'm just curious as I'm kind of
reflecting on what you're saying if
that's something that you've actively
thought about or if it's just something
that has kind of come natural to it in
terms of holding multiple perspectives
together at once I love that and I think
it does capture it that you know the way
I thought about it is being holistic you
know so mind body heart spirit and also
like perspective taking right to you
know when clients come in and tell their
story or even sometimes I'm not only
working with individuals but I work with
couples and families and so it's
important to be able to see the
circumstance from different angles
um because two people as we know can
have the quote unquote same experience
and see it totally differently so it
helps to be able to kind of step outside
of yourself and
um to be more whole right to be grounded
in the fact that we're we're complicated
people are complicated right and so when
we try to simplify it or only see people
as one thing or based on one moment in
their life we're missing the full story
so I do aim to be holistic so my parents
obviously working in the church were
very much into a spirituality but they
also were very strong about education
and so it was important for my brother
and I to really invest in our education
and then they taught us that our culture
was a gift so that you know just being
culturally rich in high school I was
able to move with my parents to Liberia
West Africa so I think also living
outside of the states gave me another
vantage point because I think sometimes
there can be a tendency for us to Center
ourselves as a nation and so to see like
the world Beyond Baltimore where I was
growing up uh really helped me to to
operate I would say with a humility and
an appreciation for the vast experiences
that people have
wow that's really great and just even a
privilege to be able to have those
different experiences in different
places uh finally that you mentioned
Liberia because the guests that we had
on the last episode actually grew up in
Liberia before and after the Civil War
and just talked about one just the
strength that he had from being in such
a strong Community before the war and
how that really helped him stay grounded
also part of the faith community even as
he moved through the Civil War but then
coming here to the states as you talked
about different perspectives realizing
that he was African but then also
realizing he was African-American and a
little bit of both and trying to
navigate through that with all the
things that have happened here in the
state so again just such a rich
perspective that he has had and which it
sounds like you've had in some different
ways as well which I think is really
really helpful and we can also do that
when we're here in the states I think
sometimes we forget about that
um as well and just that the importance
of just being exposed to people who
aren't like us and how much we can
really learn it's so true and actually
the the war in Liberia is in part how I
ended up focusing on trauma so we were
there before the war and then we ended
up being evacuated and it was that issue
of privilege as well you know by being
an American citizen I was able to get on
that plane uh to go to uh safety and so
um
operating with that awareness of you
know the impact of War right having
loved ones who are lost
um and
um just spaces and places
um the ways in which war disrupts so
much and so then it's not just like a
metaphor or something far away that you
see on the news but experiencing it up
close in a place where there are not a
lot of licensed psychologists and so you
know then asking that question of like
how do we heal right so that is a part
of how I ended up focusing on trauma
that makes a lot of sense and I think
it's really telling in terms of just all
the perspectives that you brought as
well yeah
and again so many things that kind of
peel apart one question that I was just
going to pull back to just you know as
I'm thinking about as many people are
listening to this episode I think a
comment that you made earlier about
people being complicated also realizing
that everybody's perspective or
experience in one situation can be so
different I wonder because I'm imagining
some of our listeners are hearing this
especially those who maybe maybe
navigating with people who are having
just challenges with everything going on
or even mental illness and not always
knowing how to engage people especially
if they feel like okay well this is my
loved one but I can clearly see that
their perspective is off in this
situation how does someone enter into
that without just saying no you're wrong
while also trying to understand and
validate but that also kind of help the
person navigate or get to a better place
so anything you'd be willing to share
there sure so I think uh as you named
first being willing to listen I think
often as soon as we hear something we
disagree with we jump in with a speech
or with a debate or with a correction
and so to start off with a curiosity of
like you know so tell me how you landed
there like how how did you come to
believe that or to know that
um and is there any part of you that
feels torn about it like is there any
part of you that you know wonders about
is that the fullness of the story right
and so I think coming in with a
curiosity and a question is one piece I
think another piece is respecting our
Humanity even when I don't have respect
for the opinion
right so I feel like the opinion is very
problematic and I have like no regard
for that but you are a human being
sitting across from me you are a member
of my family or whatever that connection
or relationship is
um and so on that level alone you know
by my own values there are certain ways
in which I will not speak to you but
there are certain ways I won't treat you
just as a result of honoring humanity
and then
um I think it is also important to give
yourself permission to speak the truth
as you know it because I you know used
to be one of those people that would say
you know I'm not going to say too much
to keep the peace and then I had to say
to myself whose piece are you keeping
right so the people who are saying all
kinds of outrageous things they feel
peaceful because nobody is like
challenging them or asking them a
question and and so to say it's not just
for me to be internally upset while
everybody else is comfortable but I also
have a right to express myself and my
viewpoint
um and you know developing the capacity
to do that even when you're with people
who don't agree and that was a good
learning for me because you know there
were part there were times in my life
where I was primarily surrounded by
people who agree with me so then there
are some things you don't even learn how
to articulate because everyone's always
like yup you know
we agree so it was a muscle I had to
develop
engaging with people who see the world
very differently and learning how to uh
even if they're not quote unquote
convinced but at least being able to
express
you know what I believe and why
not so good I mean I think listeners
hearing that will take so many practical
tips away
but even as you were talking I couldn't
help but not to politicize things but I
was thinking wow if we could actually
capture that especially the respecting
Humanity if you could capture that as a
nation we would be in a very different
place very different very different and
it requires that sense of safety and I
think a lot of a lot of people even at
this moment don't feel safe you know
feel like you know
um left to their own devices other
people would either wipe me out or wipe
out my community or would take away our
rights and all of these things so that
when people are in a panic state of
feeling like that they are in danger
then it's very hard to to listen with
compassion yeah so that's why I think we
need kind of those uh kind of
commonalities and or ground rules of
there are some things we can disagree on
while still honoring each other's
Humanity James Bond when said something
to the effect of we can agree to
disagree or we can be in community and
disagree as long as our dis agreement is
not a question of my right to exist
right so that's that piece of there's a
line there is a line so yes we can have
all kinds of different viewpoints but
when we start
um speaking and moving in such a way to
deny people's right to exist well then
you're gonna get a different response
so good so worth repeating in lots of
different circumstances and situations
okay remind ourselves about that enough
yeah
and again so much to think about you
know just in terms of one-on-one
individual conversation but even in
terms of nationally and societally which
I think is a good segue as well because
I wondered if you give people a little
bit about your journey to the APA and
then also what the APA represents and
does yeah so so it's been a beautiful
Journey for me within the American
Psychological Association uh and it
starts with finding like your common
interest or common Community uh American
Psychological Association is a huge
organization uh over 130 000 members and
so when we think about Notions such as
belonging or organizational home for
many of us you find a home within the
home and so we have different divisions
and one of the divisions is a society
for the psychology of women and so that
was kind of my first home within APA and
connecting with people who are committed
to bettering the lives of women and
girls and addressing our mental health
issues and so at the time soon after I
graduated from from graduate school the
president for that women's division was
Jessica Henderson Daniel okay and she is
a black woman who went on to become
apa's first black woman president wow so
then it is not by accident right that I
am in this seat now mentorship matters
yeah
she you know when I graduated with my
doctorate I was in my early 20s and she
you know took me under her wing it was
me it was a group of us because one of
her initiatives was mentorship and so
she had us all kind of articulate
professional goals and they were a group
of mentors to like help us to navigate
those spaces so along with having a
passion for women's mental health I have
a big interest in and Global issues and
so soon after I graduated the American
Psychological Association
received non-governmental organizational
status at the United Nations and so they
put out a call that they were going to
have six representatives and I had just
graduated so I said oh they're probably
not going to pick me but I'm going to
apply anyway and this is an important
point for all of my students or early
career people or even mid-career don't
count yourself out right sometimes we
eliminate ourselves it's like make them
tell you no instead of you telling
yourself no and so I was one of the
applicants I got called into New York
for the interview they were picking I
believe there were six of us for that
initial assignment and at the interview
I was the only one in the interview who
mentioned racism and coming up was the
World Conference Against Racism wow so
they needed one of the six
representatives to cover that convention
and so I ended up being selected and so
um that was a a big part of my work in
apa
um and then working as a leader and a
researcher uh in my work around trauma
really
um added to the contributions around
trauma psychology and so uh some maybe
10 years after that I had to help my
mentor the women's division is division
35.
and I said I want to be president of
division 35 before I'm 35.
it sounds like you know that and so she
said are you willing to work and I said
yes she said okay we're gonna make it
happen so 34 I was elected wow this
President they had had and uh it's funny
how your different training serves you
when we had our first meeting they were
all shocked and we're like how'd you
learn how to run a meeting they thought
they were going to have to like handle
things but growing up in the black
church there's a young people's Division
and you run your own meetings with
Robert's Rules of Order like you know
I was like I've been doing that they're
seasoned already
[Laughter]
so uh it was it was a beautiful uh year
Well you operated as a trio and then
after that people kept planting the seed
of you should run for president of the
whole thing and initially it was not an
interest of mine because I had my mind
on I wanted to do the women's group I
did it I'm kind of finished and gone
back to my academic work and uh my
private practice
um but you know timing is interesting
and important so when people circled
around the most recent time and said
there's a group of us who want to
support you are you willing to run and
for the first time I thought about it
and especially as a trauma psychologist
I was seeing both we were in the
pandemic and the realities of racial
trauma and I felt like this is the time
so I entered the race I will say
financially it was a great year to run
because all of the campaign was online
so you just send me the zoom link
instead of having to like fly all over
the country and you know do all of that
so uh virtual elections kind of um level
the playing field to some extent
so I am really grateful and excited and
about the work we've been doing so this
2023 is my presidential year but I
remain on the board for three years and
my focus areas are trauma grief and
oppression
um and we're just doing some really
exciting things that's wonderful to hear
I mean just the whole navigation and
story of it so I mean it sounds like the
need and your passion meant together and
that's what shifted yes your narrative
in terms of your willingness to jump in
yes of seeing this is like uh in years
before me a lot of presidents would make
the argument of how they could convince
uh society that psychology had something
to offer but the time that we were
living in it's like all the therapists I
knew were full so it wasn't just a
matter of like trying to convince them
we have something to offer is more the
nation and even the world we're turning
to people of our profession and saying
what can we do right people are
overwhelmed that the grief the stress
the loss
um and so it was just
a very different climate where you're
being called on as a profession uh to
really feel a void that um as in in
human terms we'd never experienced
anything like this before like the
numbers of losses
um you know it was it was it is uh
really life-changing
yeah and so important in so many ways I
mean I can just hear the passion in your
voice for all those pieces as well and
just I mean as you mentioned just it
seems like there's some gratitude also
about how people have now
caught the need and the vision but at
the same time it seals it seems at least
in my there's still a tension there as
well yeah because there's such a huge
need so I'm also curious and I'm sure
listeners are curious about you as an
organization how do you address such a
large need where a lot of people are
saying this is invaluable and others are
saying there aren't enough psychologists
especially who think about I mean just
in society in high schools on college
campuses how how are you all yeah Ryan
to navigate that one of the things is
trying to increase uh the numbers in the
field and it is I'm excited to report
out of the advanced placement courses
the AP courses in high school we have AP
psychology classes and AP Psychology is
right now the number one choice Among
The Sciences wow that so many students
are interested in selecting it they see
how it connects to their lives and so uh
in that working with Educators within
the school system because one of the
things we know is people can't pick a
career if they never heard of it
so it's like they heard of like doctor
nurse teacher firefighter and so uh
raising the awareness not only about the
field of psychology that it exists but
also the range of things that you can do
with it because you know from your own
work knowing uh it's not only about
those who are in practice but the rich
scientific work that's being done
education and then we have applied
psychology or industrial organizational
psychology so people who work you know
talk about transforming systems yeah
um and so there you know we at
Pepperdine along with our doctoral
program we have a master's program and I
tell our students whatever you
ultimately choose to do this degree will
serve you because it's going to involve
people right so even people who end up
going into law or to business having a
fundamental understanding about
psychology can help them
so that's a part of the work that we're
doing is trying to increase uh the field
um and also trying to provide advocacy
using uh psychological science and so
there are issues that people are
advocating for whether we're talking
about climate change uh whether we're
talking about access to health care but
being able to document which we can the
psychological costs consequences and
even some solutions I think helps to
inform our policy makers our legislators
and so we just on this past Monday had
one of our advocacy days where our
members set up virtual meetings with
senators and with Congressional
Representatives about you know some of
the key issues and educating them we
also provide testimony on the hill about
you know whatever the issue school
shootings whatever it is people are
facing saying what we can contribute to
the conversation so that we can come up
with some solutions that really have
impact
that's anime as encourage me here how
it's really cutting across so many
different domains and systems and as you
mentioned because that psychology is
going to be so important in so many
different ways I made a little bit maybe
selfishly just as I've noticed with the
neuroscience and someone who does a lot
of behavior Neuroscience I've talked to
University presidents who are behavioral
neuroscientists and it's amazing seeing
how they navigate with people just based
on the way that they watch people's
behaviors and how that has really helped
them yes in their leadership roles so I
think what you've mentioned to your
students is is so important that even as
you're talking about policy I mean a lot
of times probably the last 10 to 15
years we've talked a lot in this country
about needing to increase our scientific
literacy across Society yeah I think if
anything the pandemic has shown us how
important that is in terms of our
psychological understanding yeah how
much differently we would navigate if we
had that understanding in a broader
perspective and and how that even became
politicized like big attacks on science
and so it's like for some scientists it
was was their first time ever for uh
participating in a protest March
uh you know people thinking they picked
a career that was quote unquote
apolitical but somehow right somehow
here oh my goodness so yeah it's it's so
important and then when you brought up
this issue of leadership you know with
our researchers find about uh the
necessity and the value of being
relational you know whether we talk
about emotional intelligence uh or
social skills however we name that that
it's not just about the outcome meaning
the labor or like what are the goals but
as my mother would say it does matter
how you treat people
so some of these wisdoms that we find
our grandmothers or our culture could
have taught us
um but to be able to document it I think
is is so important as well in terms of
what helps when you're trying to is it
motivate people mobilize people
um and for for sustainable change yeah
yeah well again I'm I was already
grateful that you're in your role as
president but feeling even more grateful
for the work that you're doing and I'm
sort of working in teams to kind of move
a lot of these things forward across
across society as well oh thank you so
much I am so excited and you know what
one of the things I've talked about or
described it is as a movement in the
sense that many people are involved and
I tell people like 2023 is a blip on the
screen right I get president for this
year and then it's not going to be my
year anymore but what encourages me is
there are so many like-minded people in
various roles and positions in apa
outside of APA and so when we're all you
know moving at the same time then we can
really see some great things happen yeah
well said
so I know we've also talked you know
speaking of relationships and relational
things and thinking about Community
we've also talked quite a bit about
aspects of your faith growing up and so
I was curious if you could bring that
back into the conversation both in terms
of how as a field and I'm
not speculating but giving you some of
my observations it seems that psychology
has been more accepting of the fact that
faith is a large part of people's lives
so if you want to comment on that and
then also how that for you is an
integrated experience as a psychologist
and as a leader
absolutely I'm so excited to be one of
the many people who is doing bridge
building work in this area
um that when the field of psychology
started you know many of the Pioneers in
the field were people of faith it wasn't
seen as attention
um but and psychology you know literally
means study of the soul
but then as the field developed I think
in some ways trying to establish itself
as a science LED some leaders in the
field to like disconnect from
spirituality
um and it can also be like from their
own experiences uh when some people over
generalize and only see that faith-based
space as a place of shame or a place of
harm and what I do is I hold both truths
and I encourage our students to hold
both truths which is there are people
for whom it has been a life-saving
resource and that it's been healing and
nourishing and edifying and there are
people who have been harmed in those
spaces and so both things are true I
think what ends up happening is people
go from one extreme to the other so
either if you experience it as harmful
it's hard to see anything good about it
or people who love it don't believe any
of the reports that have come forward of
people who have been harmed and so we
you know know want to be really careful
about that and recognize
we never want to put people in a
position where they feel they have to
choose
right so if psychologists say dismissive
things about your faith like I literally
had a client who shared with me that
their former therapist was like very
warm until the client shared they they
were in seminary training to be a
minister and then the client the
therapist responded you seem so smart
don't tell me you believe that stuff wow
like what in the world like what an
attack on the very core of this person
so there have been statements like that
directly or indirectly that have been
made by people in the field and then on
the other side I have heard from pulpits
and you know sermons where people will
say things like you know you don't need
therapy you need to pray and presenting
this false choice you know I had a
client who her pastor literally told her
you need to stop letting those devil
people mess with your mind I already
prayed for you wow and so
um to stop
um creating attention but instead to
recognize that collectively we can
provide the support that people are so
much in need of you know I have so much
respect for a lot of times Faith
communities are like uh people's chosen
home or family in the sense that a lot
especially black churches will have
programs all week long right so the
therapist I'm like you know we might
have one hour a week right 50 minutes an
hour and uh but then the rest of the
week people may be like on their own so
they may go like Monday for choir
rehearsal Tuesday Bible study Wednesday
they're helping to feed the Homeless and
and that is their community so uh there
are things that we both give and I think
it just requires greater understanding
of each other and respect
yeah it's so well said and I mean all
those stories that you shared I mean I
think sometimes to your point about
people having one perspective about
faith either for or against based on
their personal experience then also it's
sometimes hard to again as you mentioned
earlier think about an experience
outside of your own right and how
important it is to have that
understanding but how much those
comments still happen right on both
sides because I see them all the time as
well whether I'm in the classroom or in
the lab or in the community and just
making sure that people actually have an
understanding of what's happening in
each space and it's been encouraging you
know to see the way some of those have
turned into collaborations as well right
really healthy that's you know what's
been beautiful is you know at my church
in South Los Angeles doing mental health
Ministry so you know literally we'll do
workshops on uh dealing with holiday
stress or grief and loss healthy versus
unhealthy relationships and so people
you know show up and they you know want
the knowledge they want the information
and to have it in that space that's to
know that it's okay to make use of it
right for it to be accessible I remember
at one of my former churches the pastor
talked openly
um in her sermons about having gone to
therapy and it just gave so many people
permission to feel like like we know
she's holy right we know like she prays
all the time so if she could do you know
make use of it then like maybe it could
help me too so I think you know it can
start from the top in terms of
leadership giving more room and
permission and encouragement for people
to make use of the services yeah is
really true and really healthy do you
see any roles from an organizational
standpoint for a group like the APA in
some of these conversations and if so
what what does that look like exactly
yes so as I was mentioning we have
multiple divisions and even one of our
divisions has a focus on faith
spirituality and religion
so
um it covers all the different domains
of our work so in terms of research it
is important to be able to explore both
quantitatively and qualitatively you
know what is the impact of Faith or
being a part of a faith community or
faith practices what are things that are
helpful or harmful so you know there's
something called positive religious
coping or negative religious coping so
how you picture God or think about God
is going to affect whether or not the
your faith is distressing for you or
encouraging for you right if you're
thinking like there is this figure
that's out to get me and who's mad at me
and hear all these things then yeah I'm
gonna be stressed out and then it's
going to be a negative thing in my life
versus do I really picture that as some
source that is loving that cares about
me that wants good for me then I'm going
to have a different psychological
experience as I think about my
relationship with that
and even for those who may not be
religious in the sense of like belief in
a God but as Spiritual Beings you know
what are those principles that uh guide
their lives uh because I say wherever
you have human beings involved you're
going to have
um blessing and difficulty
so even some people who will take the
god part out but you have people
gathering for a book club or gathering
for yoga whatever you have people
gathering for they're going to bring
their stuff into it and some of that
will be edifying and some of it will be
destructive so uh we just want to give
space for the the truth of you know we
are Works in progress and
um to be able to see the ideals or the
principles as opposed to people's uh
imperfect variations of trying to live
that out
yeah that's so well said It reminds me
of something you said even before we we
started this recording just in terms of
also bringing your whole authentic self
to this work as well so I know you're
talking from a leadership position but
it seems like there's also aspects of
leading by example right life as well
right and that that authentic
truth-telling to not have to pretend to
have all the answers or I think this is
a big one with faith leaders when people
are in grief or trauma they're often
asking us like why like why did this
happen and because there's not a cookie
cutter easy answer sometimes people have
said things that are harmful just trying
to create an answer and so even for us
to give room for the mystery to be able
to say I'm not sure like you know why
your mom died so young or you know and
yet right uh we're here uh to to be with
each other to support each other so I
think the humility and the honesty
really does much more than trying to
dictate some fake answer yeah yeah it's
a healthy place but not always an easy
place right right yeah
so appreciate the way that again you're
leading by example and then also just
putting things in place and have these
conversations and policies to really
help us get to that places of society
and mentioning policy when you asked
about you know things that APA is doing
there is a group of uh there are a group
of psychologists now that are working
for some guidelines to help people who
are in practice to know how to integrate
religion and spirituality respectfully
but appropriately uh so we think about
like cultural awareness people often
think about race and ethnicity maybe
they think about gender sexuality or
disability but religion often gets left
out and you know our research is fine in
general the general public endorses
higher levels of religiosity than mental
health providers so we don't want to
leave it out and want to help equip
those who are of service to others to
know how to integrate it appropriately
yeah that's so that's so well said and
encouraging to know that you're it's
also based on the research and what
you're seeing as well and then just
anecdotally I've definitely seen that in
terms of the circles that I've moved in
whether that's in Psychology circles or
even in scientific circles that people
have been having these diversity Equity
inclusion conversation conversations and
realizing that the faith component has
oftentimes been left out I think
especially last three years realizing
how harmful that can be to pretend that
it doesn't exist so that's right yeah
it's there and then we can do harm out
of ignorance you know like I had a we
have a clinic where we provide community
care for like a lower rate and you know
one of the students came to me because
she had a client who was fasting and
this was not familiar with fasting so if
you don't know what that is sure you can
creating your minds all kinds of things
that are problematic right or you can
see a problem where there's not a
problem exactly oh it's important for us
to provide the training and the
awareness so we can have understanding
well so encouraging I know I've said
this a few times with the APA is
definitely in good hands oh thank you so
much I'm grateful for the opportunity to
serve and really blessed to be able to
serve with a number of really uh
incredible people and glad that you are
in the field as well yeah definitely
grateful as well well this has been a
really rich conversation went too fast
so many things we could have touched on
but any last pieces that you want to
leave the listeners with in terms of
what gives you hope on a day-to-day
basis yes so I want to say one of the
things that gives me hope uh is the Arts
artistic expression and so for us to
think about ways to both express
ourselves through the Arts but also to
engage with other people's Artistry so
that can be in music I tell people think
of a theme song play it in the morning
before you start working or engaging
with your family moving our bodies or
dancing
poetry and then some people will say I'm
not artsy but it might be culinary arts
the way you cook the way you wear your
hair the way you decorate your office or
your home so that creativity I think it
helps us to think out of the box which
is always a good thing and uh then the
last thing I would just say is to
remember your own care often we are in
service of other people but we don't
want to erase abandon or neglect
ourselves and so I hope you will do
something for you on today
well thank you so much for sharing that
with our listeners words of wisdom and
for any who want to know more or hear
more about some of the things that Dr
Tim has mentioned you can definitely
check out her TED Talks there's lots of
Rich insights there as well so again
thank you so much for being here on the
Addie Hour podcast just for your work
and for all that you came to share with
our listeners as well today definitely
appreciate it oh thank you so much I
appreciate you having me of course
foreign
[Music]